Today, I want to talk about one of the most
important moments in recent cinema history.
Perhaps, you remember it.
It went like this: "Don’t you know who I
am?
I’m the juggernaut, bitch!
I’m the juggernaut, bitch!"
In case you weren't spending hundreds of hours
on the internet in the early aughts, this
line from the 2006 summer blockbuster, X-Men:
The Last Stand, was cribbed straight from
an amateur parody video - "I’m the Juggernaut
bitch!”
"Motherf**ker, I'ma whoop your ass."
"Silly bitch, your weapons cannot harm me.
Don't you know who the f**k I am?
I'm the juggernaut!"
It inspired a wildly popular meme, which,
against all odds, traveled from the depths
of the web to the big screen.
X-Men’s reference to Internet culture was
no mere comedic moment.
It was the birth of an entirely new relationship
between Hollywood and the internet.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on the Memeification
of Actors.
And no spoilers ahead...
I guess.
This X-Men thing wasn’t an isolated incident,
either.
Just months earlier, the world’s most prolific
speaker of profanity, Samuel L. Jackson, saw
his own fame eclipsed by a series of gifs
when his new film, Snakes on a Plane, was
announced.
It quickly became an online meme-ified sensation.
Most notably, a couple of Internet fans created
an overdubbed R-rated audio trailer for the
film, inspired by Jackson’s role in Pulp
Fiction.
"I did not ask for motherf**king snakes on
my motherf**king plane!"
Unable to ignore the Internet’s insatiable
demand for good, old-fashioned Samuel L Jackson
f-bombs, the film’s producers scheduled
reshoots to add new scenes that played up
the ridiculousness, including the now-famous
line: "I have had it with these motherf**king
snakes on this motherf**king plane!"
Samuel L. Jackson’s public persona was crucial
to the internet frenzy.
The incredibly salient motherf**king mantra
of the film’s viral bubble exploited Jackson’s
firmly established on-screen image as the
potty-mouthed badass.
"Say 'what' again!
Say 'what' again, I dare you!
I double dare you, motherf**ker.
Say 'what' one more, g*ddamn time!"
Then, to great humorous effect, it placed
said-badass into a delightfully absurd situation:
the greatest reptilian invasion in the history
of aviation.
Fans were explicitly waiting to see how Samuel
L Jackson, the celebrity entity, would respond
to the scenario.
They were envisioning some kind of fabricated
combination of the characters played by Jackson
and the man, himself.
This moment represents what we’re going
to call the "memeification of actors."
While X-Men’s Juggernaut moment, or Snakes
on a Plane, may seem like a bizarre blip on
our collective cultural radar, it’s much
more than that, encapsulating a revolutionary
breakdown in the separation between film and
fan.
And yet, at the same time, it represents the
next step in a process that’s preoccupied
Hollywood’s efforts since its earliest days.
While the memeification of actors is new,
the processes that lead up to it aren't.
So how did we get to this moment, a time when
Sad Keanu can literally inspire the sad vengeance-seeking
hero of John Wick or when Ryan Gosling is
known as the face of the “Hey Girl” meme
to scores of people who have never seen his
films?
First, we have to understand something called
serialization, but not in the narrative sense.
So, what is this kind of serialization?
Most literally, a franchise.
Most metaphorically, according to media scholar
P. David Marshall, you can compare it to a
series of related products, such as a car
or an on-screen performance, “that are stylistically
linked.”
Marshall argues that serialization fulfilled
a need of early day Hollywood producers: it
helped them cement an individual movie star’s
persona into the public consciousness, thus
setting them apart from the rest of the pack.
In the early Hollywood star system of the
1920s, branding celebrities was an economic
strategy, a way for studios to make their
films stand out in a crowded market.
It was quite literally product differentiation.
In a sea of attractive movie stars, cultivating
demand for individual actors like your resident
‘Cowboy” or “Blonde Bombshell” was
like popularizing Diet Coke to the other studios’
“soda pop.”And so, a complex infrastructure
of public relations professionals, star magazines,
and studios grew in the pursuit of moulding
actors into name brands.
Once a star became a household name, studios
could then exploit said star’s fame by making
the exact same, generally sh*tty serialized
movies over and over, using their resident
“good girl,” "Casanova,” or “vamp.”
When people got bored, actors could be cast
against type, and thus consciously evoke the
very same audience expectations.
For example, Schwarzenegger became a brand,
so the studios gave you Terminator, Commando,
Predator, The Running Man, etc.
Tired of that? then, they gave you Junior
and Jingle All the Way, where our Last Action
Hero has to fight not with aliens, but with
Sinbad for a toy.
With this serialization of performances, came
what Marshall calls "celebrity personnage.”
Personnage refers to “a structure of familiarity
for the audience, but also a structure of
performance for the actor.”
In other words, a feedback loop of typecasting.
Sometimes, that familiarity becomes so encompassing
that it literally supplants any sense of the
actor as an autonomous being.
When you picture classic stars like James
Dean, you picture them exactly as they looked
and behaved on screen, not their real selves.
You could say the same about Samuel L Jackson,
who, for all I know, goes home and soothes
his children to sleep with the calming refrain,
“go the f**k to sleep.”
Because branded stars equaled easy money,
studios invested in them heavily, and Hollywood
celebrity “personnage” was mediated by
the aforementioned PR reps, star magazines,
agencies and more.
They worked in synergy to create and safeguard
celebrity reputations.
Back in these good old days, a celebrity name
was enough to generate reliable box office
returns.
But that’s all changed.
Today, not even heavyweights like Tom Cruise
or J-Law are totally safe bets.
That’s partially because celebrity identity
no longer belongs exclusively to powerful
movie executives.
Why?
Because the internet.
It allows us to actively participate in creating
the narrative of each celebrity, giving us,
as scholar Paul Mcdonald writes, “the opportunity
for an interactive construction of star discourse
that was not possible with previous channels
of mass communication.”
That’s changed our position in the food
chain of media.
According to Marshall, the audience member
is now a “hybrid of producer and user that
is engaged in the media consumption/production”
or a “prosumer” and this fact is “redefining
the dynamics of popular culture.”
Which brings us to memes.
The Internet meme is comparatively more egalitarian
than most art forms.
It’s nearly effortless to make one, anyone
with an Internet connection, the know-how
and a couple of minutes of free time can do
it.
And, unlike literally everything else in the
cultural industry, they’re typically not
made to generate money, they’re made for
the lulz.
Because memes operate somewhat outside the
realm of economics, they can actually act
as an authentic intervention in our consumption
of culture.
Particularly given the source material: memes
can pull from literally anywhere, since we
have access to nearly the entire history of
American modern visual culture at our fingertips.
As a result, we can use memes to evoke powerful,
shared moments of our collective cultural
identity.
And we are doing that literally every day.
As a result, so much of our visual exposure
to celebrities is happening via user-generated
culture.
This means a more level playing field.
Back in the day, fandom meant passively reading
canned stories in gossip magazines or joining
a celebrity fan club.
Today, the fan can actively shape the way
they and their entire social networks view
individual celebrities via dank memes.
All hail the great prosumer!
But now that we have the means to meme - what
are we doing with it?
When it comes to celebrities, three major
things.
First, some memes are reaffirming celebrity
brands and making them even more powerful.
Consider the Sad Keanu meme.
The meme was instantly comprehensible because
it exaggerated pre-existing notions of Keaunu
as vulnerable, his life as tragic.
It emerged and spread organically in June
2010, after paparazzi published the now-famous
photo.
While the meme began with words superimposed
on the image, Photoshoppers got creative,
and suddenly Sad Keanu was kickin it with
everyone from Stalin, to the Breakfast Club
Brat Pack.
At one point, Sad Keanu was a more popular
Google search than Oprah.
Hollywood had a knee-jerk reaction to the
blowup, issuing takedown notices to sadkeanu.com.
RIP.
The sad man himself expressed annoyance about
the meme’s characterization of him — "I
mean, do I wish that I didn't get my picture
taken, and, while I was eating a sandwich
on the streets of New York?
Yeah."
But whether Keanu is or isn’t sad, the widespread
sharing of the image has the power to literally
shape our conception of his personnage.
Because the image of him looking sad was serialized
widely across the internet, the preconception
of his sadness, confirmed and solidified that
personnage.
Until, inevitably, Hollywood found a way to
capitalize on it with: John Wick.
The film and its titular role, which feels
tailor made for Keanu, casts him as a sad
action hero, creating a sort of feedback loop
between his memed self and the performances
he gives.
Sometimes memes can also recontextualize the
meaning of a celebrity brand and tap into
a larger, broader cultural sentiment.
That process can be totally subconscious.
So, let’s go back to Samuel L Jackson, who
as previously discussed, saw his badass “personnage”
set the Internet ablaze.
Now, to be clear, the intertextual commentary
about Samuel L Jackson’s unique brand of
badassery is not unique to the Internet.
You can trace it back at least to the days
of Chappelle Show in 2004 — "No, I can't
stop yellin', cuz that’s how I talk, ya
ain't never seen my movies?"
Since then, memes have reaffirmed and hyperbolized
his persona, giving the commodified “Samuel
L Jackson” even more value via increased
recognition and visibility.
But at the same time, there’s an underlying
explanation for why Samuel L Jackson, and
the particular movie “Snakes on a Plane,”
captured so much Internet attention beyond
Jackson’s famous potty mouth.
"Personality goes a long way."
Consider the specific setting: a post-9/11
world, in which Jackson, a beloved figure
of strength, saves an airplane from attack
the perfect encapsulation of post 9/11 anxiety
and our collective desire to feel safe.
This performance helped solidify Jackson’s
badass rep, which then became a feedback loop
in which Jackson was repeatedly cast to play
the character of “Samuel L. Jackson the
actor.”
Most recently, that’s landed Jackson a 9-film
deal with Marvel.
"Motherf--" "Motherf--"
Meme-making isn’t just a fantastic procrastination
tool: it’s the paradigm-shifting act of
a modern prosumer.
What’s more, our ability to make memes,
i.e. to actively participate in cultural production,
inherently changes the way we view visual
culture.
In seeing movies and tv shows, in part, as
source material for great memes, we’re developing
a critical distance from the media we consume.
If you’ve ever made a meme, you’ve probably
experienced that light-bulb moment, when you’re
watching a Youtube video and thought, “Man,
that would look really dope on loop.”
In that moment, you were thinking less like
a consumer, passively waiting for the next
thing to happen on screen, and more like a
prosumer, searching for your next source of
inspiration in your day-to-day media consumption.
So, what does this mean for the future of
Hollywood casting, and celebrity persona?
Well, a few things.
First of all, it means that the cultural currents
of Internet fandom could become increasingly
visible in popular entertainment, such as
the potential Netflix heist movie announced
in 2017, to be based on this classic 2014
meme of Rihanna and actress Lupita Nyong'o
sitting together at a fashion show.
Now, unfortunately, Danny Devito won’t be
playing Detective Pikachu… yet.
It also means that actor identities will become,
if anything, increasingly reliant on the Internet
masses.
The rapid serialization unique to the medium
of the meme means it will continue to have
the power to create some of the key defining
moments of popular celebrity and popular culture,
sometimes overnight.
And it will guarantee that Bill Murray will
keep wishing you happy birthday for years
to come.
So, what do you think?
Are memes creating a new class of prosumers
or are they just good for the lulz and an
upvote?
Let us know what you think in the comments,
and as always, thanks for watching, guys.
Peace.